le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
vieillir chez soi entouré de ses proches
c'est le rêve de toute personne âgée le
maintien à domicile permet de garder une
vie active et des liens sociaux des
conditions idéales pour se maintenir en
forme physique et mentale le plus
longtemps possible à saint denis rita
est l'exemple même du bien vieillir la
doyenne fête ses 100 ans cette année
encore très active est parfaitement
lucide elle vit chez sa fille et son
gendre et reçoit régulièrement autour
d'elle toute sa famille
[Musique]
oh
elle n'a rien perdu de sa vision ni de
sa dextérité pourtant dans quelques
semaines rita fêtera ses 100 ans un
enfer étaient dans le rouge
et ce n'est pas ce siècle écoulé qui
arrêtera la dynamique dionysienne ce
matin du fait mon lit je classe tous mes
affaires parce que quand je veux dire
manière je lis beaucoup je fais les mots
casey j'aime bouger bouger pour la
marque
[Musique]
1-1 déambulateur mais la plupart du
temps
rita a travaillé comme greffier au
tribunal de saint denis après la mort de
son mari ne supportant pas la solitude
elle s'installe chez sa fille marie
renée
ma fille et ensuite vous voyez
ce que je veux je lis je cours je suis
[Musique]
marie-renée se souvient encore de la
requête de sa mère il y a quinze ans un
jour elle est arrivée ici je la revois
encore montées d'escaliers là et en me
disant rené je vais vendre ma maison ma
villa et est-ce que je peux venir
habiter chez toi moi je lui ai répondu
maman
j'ai un mari je ne peux pas prendre la
décision
moi de te dire tout de suite oui je lui
demande s'il me dit oui a pas de
problème pour guy legendre accueilli
rita est un geste naturel je n'ai pas
connu de moments
en fin de peine n'est plus l'âge de deux
ans et j'ai très très grand affectif en
ce qui concerne la famille moi même je
suis en train de vieillir
j'aimerais un jour est dans une dans ma
famille au lieu d'être dans une maison
de retraite la famille un élément
primordial pour rita la centenaire a six
enfants 17 petits enfants trente trois
arrière petits enfants et une arrière
arrière petite fille
toute une tribu qui s'est réunie en
l'honneur de la doyenne le temps d'un
goûter
c'est une personne vraiment importante
dans la famille parce que c'est comme le
pilier de la famille que c'est notre
arrière grand mère donc c'est celle qui
est la plus âgée tous les week-ends on
vient la voir et c'est plus facile
d'être en contact quand quand elle et
quand elle vit chez la famille parce
qu'on peut aller la voir quand on veut
s'il n'y a pas des horaires spécifiques
pour pour dire l'iphone à une la visite
et on a vraiment c'est de chance de la
voir là en fait tu seras d'abord mon
anniversaire c'est le principal je te
fais gros bisous et à les amener à
bientôt dans le bon sens je ne peux pas
vivre sais pas je ne vous pas tout seul
j'aime bien l'ambiance genou toujours
son gay ils sont bien ils sont et son
front tous impeccables c'est ma raison
de vivre tout ça tout ça aux toiles
noires zimory sans ça je crois pas je
vais vouloir résister
le maintien à domicile pour mieux
vieillir entouré des siens c'est ce que
vise le conseil départemental pour
encourager ce mode de vie la
collectivité décline plusieurs
dispositifs d'aidé à domicile nous
préférons que les gens restent chez eux
encadrés de leurs familles à nous
d'offrir à la famille des moyens en
versant l'allocation personnalisée à
l'autonomie
ou bien les ménages ou encore en aidant
ces familles à être accompagné par
différents autres dispositifs quand ils
sont
quand ils doivent être accompagnés au
niveau du soin puisque même quand on est
malade sur dix vous pouvez rester chez
vous si vous avez un apk avec des
prestataires qui viennent adonis
les gens restent actifs en bonne santé
et heureux de vivre que s'ils sont
accompagnés et ça c'est avoue qu'elle me
voir moi faire double emploi mais en
pointant artisans françois
c'est donc entouré de ses proches que
rita célébrera dans quelques jours son
centième anniversaire
derrière elle un beau parcours mais la
doyenne se concentre surtout sur les
beaux moments il reste à venir
[Musique]
le maintien à domicile des personnes
âgées vise à préserver des liens
familiaux et sociaux il permet aux
gramounes de conserver son autonomie le
plus longtemps possible pour encourager
le maintien à domicile le département
propose plusieurs dispositifs comme
l'aide ménagère légale en facultative
qui permet de financer des heures de
service ménager selon sa situation
l'allocation personnalisée à l'autonomie
est une aide financière visant les
personnes dépendantes à domicile ou en
établissement les personnes âgées
peuvent aussi bénéficier du chèque santé
il permet d'acquérir une couverture
maladie ou de l'amélioration de
l'habitat selon leur condition de
ressources pour plus de renseignements
ne manquez pas la journée départementale
des personnes âgées le dimanche 23
octobre au jardin de l'état
[Musique]
m